alors pour réussir son bac 3 solutions
le bachotage la chance ou la fraude
d'après une enquête ils ne sont qu'une
centaine à tricher sur quatre cent mille
candidats il faut dire qu'une grande
partie des 125 millions de francs du
budget du bac sert à décourager les
fraudeurs précaution qui n'a pas suffi à
empêcher la fraude du siècle c'était il
ya six ans en 1983
cinq lycéens avaient cambriolé le
rectorat pour lire les sujets l'un
d'entre eux témoigne
il est devenu journaliste reportage
jeanne moreau christophe camillieri ce
midi sortie du lycée à orléans il y a
huit ans olivier calon j'étais l'un de
ses élèves un élève dont se souviennent
en cours ceux qui passent le bac cette
année
un élève qui a défrayé la chronique avec
quatre autres lycéens en décidant de ne
pas respecter la règle l'expédition a
débuté ici une nuit de juin à l'arrière
du rectorat escaladé la grille se
faufiler à l'intérieur du bâtiment par
une fenêtre ouverte puis trouver le bon
bureau ne demandera que quelques minutes
aux apprentis cambrioleurs l'armoire
était grande ouverte
though he don't fit un exemplaire de
tous les originaux présent pour aller
les faire photocopier au dehors toute
allure nous les avons ramené remis à
leur place et ni vu ni connu
on a fermé tous aucune trace pas
d'effraction les clés étaient accrochés
à l'accueil
cette année là les fraudeurs sentiront à
trop bon compte pour ne pas avoir envie
de retourner une fois encore une fois de
trop au rectorat et deux personnes qui
nous avait accompagnés et qui à l'époque
était en première et avait réussi à
avoir des sujets du bac français
malgré nos mises en garde de cet
exceptionnel coup de bol entre
guillemets de tout trouver sans se faire
repérer cette année là ils sont quand
même retourné pour faire pâmer pop un d
eux sont fait lamentablement piqué avec
les sujets aujourd'hui olivier calenge
mais s'en être bien tiré
3000 francs d'un enduit mois de prison
avec sursis des petits boulots et depuis
peu le journalisme il est le seul à
parler du bac 84 les autres eux ont
préféré oublier la garde à vue les
examens
10 et les études compromise par un coup
de tête d'adolescent je leur ferai
certainement plus mais c'est vrai que
c'était assez excitant de rentrer une
nuit dans les tours et de jouer les jo
ni aucun regret bouchard
[Musique]